ciao ragazzi è tornato nella puntata di
cucina buttata oggi sono felice perché
lo vedete vicino a me si torna a
cucinare con me è quello che faremo oggi
è molto semplice un sacco di persone
hanno amato e amano i video delle torte
in tazza che vengono fatti in due
secondi all'interno delle colonne io
stesse io stesso ne ho fatte in passato
un pochino ma adesso avete un momento di
uno vedere se queste che faremo oggi
funzionano 2 se sono buone 3 e leggere
la nostra vincitrice siamo pronti un po
di paura di cosa a me non mi sembra di
aver mai dimostrato che io il microonde
non fossimo migliori amici anzi mi sono
sentito stretto con tutti questi fuochi
e tutte queste cose che tu hai voluto
gianmarco tra parentesi perché tu sei
stato il primo a dire iniziamo a fare le
cose più serie io le cose che ho sempre
detto falliremo e che cosa abbiamo fatto
fino ad oggi
fallito possiamo partire partiamo ciak
azione appena bene ricetta avremo
bisogno di tre ingredienti semplici e
questa qui che possiamo parlarne secondo
di questa tassa presa ieri potter
studios a londra approccio è un ricordo
sarei stato disposto forse a pagare
qualsiasi cifra almeno 15 sterline a un
secondo di più aveva un po avrei fatto
prima pagando una retta di hogwarts
partiamo subito con la prima ricetta che
sopra illumineremo lakata veloce ma
scusami questa qui è la torta nutella
inutile dalla juve più appropriata
proprio vabbè andiamo così per fare la
torta nutella avremo bisogno di tre
ingredienti nutella farina e un nuovo
mamma né ragazze ce la siamo sfondato a
pranzo questa qui era bene che sfondava
naturale mangiato o no e fate un bel
cucchiaio di nutella per sempre io
sinceramente voglio tornare a essere
veramente un pisa culo in cucina perché
mi sono rotto le palle di fare le cose
fatte bene che non vengono molto meglio
fatte male che non ho capito cosa
intendo capito è fatte bene che non
vengono della studi di parte male che
non vengono massimi geni ma da grande
personalità
cos'è dice vi prendiamo l'uomo e lo
apriamo dentro adriano gli utenti
grembiule ma secondo me non serve
grembiule aver mirato che cosa
intelligente di dire certe l'ha lanciata
dai sei il grembiule si infila nel sette
ma come la magia
sta meglio oh mio dio dio ci sembrava ma
che cosa è strafelice
quanto ci vuole farina chiaro per
chiunque ci segue da casa e di più o
meno in modo da creare un composto la
torta sono già adulti e mezzo se vi
interessa anche il fatto che stiamo
cucinando questa torta è già pronta
vogliamo fare una cosa la facciamo
riposare e li creiamo tutte e poi li
informiamo insieme seconda torta è
arrivato quindi il momento di questa
seconda ricetta gli ingredienti questa
volta sono un po di più perché faremo
una torta che io ho ribattezzato a
ribattezzarlo ribattezzato ribattezzato
la cookie torta perché in realtà stiamo
facendo un enorme biscotto dentro la
tazza questa è quella che poi assaggiare
più di tutte perché mi intriga proprio
se posso dirlo ma non è un biscotto se
dentro la c'è stato da antistronzi sulle
sedie mente non può essere un biscotto
su una tazza mi chiedo allora prendiamo
nel burrone quanto bene sempre molto
chiaro ma vorrei un biscotto che
richiami un pochino la cucina francese
anche trenta secondi e microonde quello
che avremmo non si è sciolto nel video
lo abbiamo visto l'hai letta una fettina
infine più fine nel senso con un milione
io credo che devono essere delle ricette
che una persona fa un po a casa non è
che deve stare lì a sporca la bilancia
27 piattini ora noi lo facciamo
semplicemente perché è molto più carino
una donna e mi hanno detto gli
ingredienti burro gocce di cioccolato
zucchero di canna da zucchero semolato
un uovo sale grosso farina sale grosso
che cosa vuol dire questo
è un tipo di sale non è grosso tubo del
prodotto se volete seguire 0 questo
canale localistica messo un top in
giornate come così come fa maria
replicare le ricette che todt un
estratto di vaniglia questo non avevi
detto tra le boe estratto di vaniglia
ok e sfrutto divani bilanci sono
coscienza ma quanto un po dopo torino
non sono in un bicchiere per raggiungere
il mio tuorlo d uovo o quando state male
di scambi con nicolò sì quando gli si
chiede il naso a minare un bicchiere
vale un ultimo appello va bene vedi
consiglio di comunque è stato limitato
considerando anche di bicchieri
immaginiamo un sacro mazza bravissimo in
una cascina dentro si si si si
axolute e un po di farina la cosa deve
diventare in realtà è una challenge a
che è stata più distratti cina deve
essere un po più secco un po più secco
mazza ceramista
che cosa le gocce di cioccolato un pop
ottima qualità temo davvero un paesaggio
erato cioccolato viola non in realtà dal
tuo amici ci torna questo risultato
ok passiamo all'ultimo per la passiamo
gianluca preparazione per la terza e
ultima ricetta avremmo bisogno dei
seguenti ingredienti allora burro burro
di arachidi un uovo sale zucchero cacao
in polvere come si chiamano gocce di
cioccolato pepite no l'ac rimini
cioccolato una bustina di lievito una di
vanillina e infine la farina passiamo
subito al procedimento allora che
dobbiamo devono sciogliere il burro come
prima dai mai mai mai esagerato questo
qui può andar bene ma dall'altro era
così ma vai a 30 secondi
e intanto vogliamo le cose ma dove il
filo che li si vedono
si dobbiamo un attimo togliere
provocante a microonde questa roba
due le metti poi cosa dovevo fare
burro di arachidi prima di ogni altra
cosa e che cosa ci siamo integrati
niente offre stato il burro fosse nuovo
il burro
quanto però in chiave durata la
produzione per darmi un cucchiaino per
favore ma bicchiere d'acqua dalla
produzione
mamma mia quanto altro recipiente
zucchero non fallo che lo sto per
prendere tremare ok non ho più voce in
capitolo
ok zucchero da quanto notte del muro
scusate il cucchiaio che era frode i
processi intanto non avrebbe sporcato
che si sarebbe capito cristallizzato lo
zoom e solo quando attuando ma non
sarebbe capito dalle queste cose e ti fa
lavorato con la stessa tassa poi ma sta
cercando di dire premio la fisica che il
mio cane
wow ci mettiamo un bell'uomo dentro ci
ha preso per il culo
e poi dobbiamo mischiare e metterlo
dentro si poteva fare tutto quanto una
sola tazza se vorrà fare tutto in una
sola tazza regala fra polizia e bande
anche come luminosa e nausea il tuo
dover seguire le regole sì signore
però già marsi signore io giro qua cosa
dobbiamo ottenere con questo po di
farina by un bel top una volta
gerarchica del colpo devo rifare tutto
nella stessa piazza
ok in silenzio mi partendo da se anzi no
rimango in silenzio si capisce tante
cose molto invitante mamma mia ragazzi
nel ieri stanno prendendo più densa sono
triple che di ieri il cacao in toto o
ricchi sul cerchio ora girando
soddisfatto del proprio posto no più
farina sito di fare per favore ma non
esco ascolta e dall'altra parte lui
dovrebbe essere un po più scuro e ora a
metterla dentro
ok vedete comunque era fondamentale fare
parola ministeri è vero perché persone
finite ognuna da una parte diversa un
occhio miglioramento e ora puoi andare
con le gocce di cioccolato
scusami non so in che mondo in quel
momento al video io ho incominciato a
perdere autorità per diventare un mero
esecutore ho messo le gocce fatto nelle
due vanno cocktail voluta questa è una
cosa ma il lievito quando veniva messo
visto che sta tra ingredienti o beh
impoverito non c'è stata più baking
powder perfetto lievito cazzo e lo sai
quando quando prima di unirli chiamo
movimento nel raking powder anzi powder
preghiamo dio ragazzi qua bisogna
pregare io non ho trovato mattine
mangerai gr.a legati dai segnali che
stai per mettere tutto nel cose devo
tutto a ragazzi dove segnale trasmettere
tutto quanto eccoci qui finalmente con
le nostre tre tazze abbiamo qui quella
lì alla nutella più nera che mai questa
qui al cookie e questa richiesta uscendo
ragazzi da sola è già fuori praticamente
forse ho messo troppo in così breve
tempo le loro attività
perché magico facciamone una alla volta
ok ci stanno più possibilità di fallire
che di andar bene hai lasciato il frigo
aperto lega l'ultimo chi ha bevuto per
ultimo io ho preso l'acqua e me ne fa un
vago ricordo che l'ho buttata neppure un
minuto tanto l'aspetto volevo ricordarvi
che se ti è piaciuto questo video potete
metterci paolo come favore personale se
non vi dispiace di un bel po di pollici
in su per il ma sotto e se non avete già
fatto iscriverti a questo canale insomma
a noi farebbe solamente che piacere
detto ciò dovesse vedere
[Musica]
prendiamo tutti quanti prendiamo tutti
quanti di un cucchiaio a testa per fatto
interessante di tanto a questo qui un
minuto mentre messaggiamo questa mattina
dal balcone la sentenza perché
restivo
ma c'è una consistenza veramente
particolare troppa farina
e che è una merda come il late roio
chiamata all'inizio la cacata veloce è
vero è vero il giornale quanto deve
essere questo dai 12 minuti è al momento
nel pubblico veramente immangiabile
immangiabile
sembra come mangiare una gomma bollente
certo lo zucchero per caso se ci
avessimo insomma lo zucchero e
appoggiato anche il sapore non è male
malissimo siamo sempre su un
insufficienza di due anni occhio perché
settimana è l'ultimo nato ondate
risultato cosa questa eccitante
mamma mia e tv pan di spagna uso di
lorenza sta cosa è qualcosa di strano
rango arachidi ha voluto rapido con la
più buona
reagan a cagare parata lo senti sale ho
mai detto di mettermi un po però la
migliore 5 e mezzo secondo me secondo me
la migliore era questa spesa rega è
salvo e se sai sale zucchero scusa
serata se un tot perché tu non la
rispetta e rispetti perché ho fatto un
po di bello fallire
microonde è vero coerenti ci siamo
impegnati no è venuta buona
no no l'algebra no non lo fa sì quindi
noi ci vediamo la prossima domenica con
una nuova puntata di cucina buttata
capito tu pensavi che ci fosse ancora
una grande chiacchiere in realtà è già
finito prima
sale che lo allora ero io il problema
non è salutato sale paltrow ciao